in the marvel universe the eternal known
as icarus has been around for a very
long time hundreds of thousands of years
in fact but to many comic fans he's
still something of a mystery this is
everything you need to know about icarus
from eternals perhaps the most important
thing about icarus is that he isn't just
any other eternal he's a so-called prime
eternal but that hasn't always been the
case after the godlike cronus's fateful
experiments with cosmic energy leaves
his mind separated from his body his two
sons zorus and alas fight a conflict
over the future of the eternals when
zorus wins alas leaves for jupiter's
moon titan where he will later become
father to thanos then after the
remaining eternals form the collective
eternal consciousness known as the uni
mind it chooses zorus to be the prime
maternal zoros is later killed in battle
with the celestials and thena is
selected as the new prime maternal in
1986's eternals issue 9 after icarus
accuses teen of treason over her loyalty
to her deviant lover crow thiena passes
on the role of prime eternal to icarus
being the prime maternal means more than
getting a fancy title though among other
things whoever is named by maternal is
given the privilege of initiating the
formation of the
an act that has saved both the eternals
and earth on more than one occasion
icarus boasts a wide array of abilities
including impressive super strength and
durability he expertly wields cosmic
energy has often seen blasting from his
eyes and he can manipulate this ability
in various ways
unsurprisingly these powers serve him
well in battle in 1977's eternals issue
14 issue 15 icarus goes toe to toe with
a cosmic-powered robot designed to look
act and display powers similar to the
incredible hulk well not the real deal
the cosmic-powered hulk robot is no
pushover and on top of that icarus has
faced all kinds of similarly powerful
challenges over the years similar to the
other eternals icarus can fly and while
they aren't his most used abilities he's
also been shown to have both the
capacity to teleport and use some
low-level psychic powers
if you're familiar with the world of
ancient myth then you've probably
already guessed that the name icarus is
inspired by icarus the boy who flew too
close to the sun and in the mid-80s
marvel miniseries the connection between
icarus and icarus became much more
literal in greco-roman myth icarus is
the son of daedalus a genius forced by
king minos to design a labyrinth to
contain the terrifying minotaur when
king minos imprisons settlers and his
family so that the secret of the
labyrinth can never be revealed daedalus
constructs his own flying machines out
of bird feathers and wax upon their
escape daedalus wants his son not to fly
too close to the sun but icarus ignores
him and when the wax of icarus flying
contraption melts he plummets to his
death in 1986's eternals issue 5 is
revealed that in the marvel universe the
eternal icarus was actually the
inspiration for this story centuries ago
icarus had a son named icarus one day
believing his father to be imprisoned by
deviants icarus attempted to use a
mechanical flying device to find his
father like the icarus of myth the boy
flew too high and eventually fell to his
death after learning of his son's fate
the eternal named himself icarus to
honor his fallen child
one of the x-men's most infamous
villains is apocalypse who first shows
up using that name in 1986's x factor
issue 5. it's since been revealed that
apocalypse had faced a number of heroes
before he met any of the x-men however
for example he fought a younger thor in
2013's uncanny avengers issue six and at
one point he even faced off against
icarus and the eternals in the 2001 shot
new eternals apocalypse now the evil
mutant unleashes his latest sworded
scheme icarus some apocalypse don't meet
face to face until toward the end of the
story but when they do it's suggested
that they're actually old enemies the
details are left a little murky but
icarus refers to the villain as n
sabaner suggesting their last encounter
was centuries ago when apocalypse was
better known by that name icarus also
claims that he'd believed apocalypse had
died in their last meeting at first that
might not seem like much of a reveal
after all as a popular marvel comics
villain apocalypse is legally required
to die and be resurrected every few
years but the fact that icarus and his
brethren so thoroughly defeated
apocalypse as to believe him dead proves
just how formidable these heroes can be
who do you think's gonna lead the
avengers
i could lead them
[Music]
since the eternals tend to live separate
from humanity it's perhaps
understandable that some of them aren't
exactly thrilled to be sharing the earth
with humans consequently some eternals
aren't quite as dedicated to their
safekeeping as they should be icarus
however has always done everything he
can to defend humankind ever since
ancient times icarus has gone above and
beyond to protect the people of earth
from his guidance of noah's ark to
safety all the way up to his allegiance
with the avengers icarus has always
advocated for the humans despite having
advanced beyond them in many ways this
is why when most of the eternals leave
earth after their battle with the
inhuman villain maelstrom it cares as
one of the few selected by the uni mind
to stay behind and continue to use his
powers to protect those who can't
protect themselves
the idea of a superhero taking on a
relatively mundane job is nothing new
spider-man has been a photographer
daredevil has been a lawyer and the
god-like superman has enjoyed a thriving
career as a reporter for the daily
planet regardless it still feels like
kind of a shock that the 1985 eternals
miniseries finds a noble and powerful
icarus working as a professional
wrestler in 1985's eternals issue 1 it
becomes apparent that icarus has joined
the ranks of marvel's unlimited class
wrestling federation as ike at the
iceberg harris the issue even shows him
in action in his wrestling dicks and
judging by the applause and cheers this
is hardly iceberg's first time in the
rink of course it's eventually revealed
icarus didn't join the ucwf because he
enjoys hitting people with folding
chests in fact icarus has been climbing
the ucwf's ranks for the chance to take
on the wrestler enigma who's actually
cataphracts the mighty a deviant villain
in disguise the ucwf was one of the more
prominent marvel fictional organizations
in the 1980s along with icarus a number
of other heroes have joined and wrestled
in the ucwf though the most prominent
was none other than ben grimm
icarus and the other eternals claimed
the distinction of starring in one of
the few comic books that neil gaiman has
written for marvel comics comic book
wise gaiman is best known for his
groundbreaking dc vertigo sandman series
though he's written a few projects for
marvel 2. in 2003 he wrote 1602 which
introduced early 17th century european
versions of most of marvel's most
popular heroes then after marvel
acquired the rights to miracle man
gaiman wrote subsequent issues for the
long lost character and in 2006 he
teamed up with the legendary artist john
romita jr to bring to life another
dormant property the eternals the
mid-earth's eternals mini-series begins
with each of the godlike beings stripped
of their memories and living as ordinary
humans the speedster makari for example
is living as mark curry a med student
cersei is a party organizer athena is a
scientist working for stark industries
and zorus is an alcoholic homeless man
it's eventually revealed that their
memories have been stripped by the
mischievous sprites but before that
becomes clear it's icarus who sets out
to find the eternals and reawaken their
old memories
a few years later the eternals fell to a
horrible fate and icarus was the last of
them to survive when avengers relaunched
in 2018 it was led by a storyline
involving the dark celestials a group of
evil cosmic beings after the corpses of
the true celestials fall to earth the
avenger sets out on a quest that
ultimately reveals a dark secret about
the eternals humanity and the celestials
themselves when iron man travels to the
eternal's home of olympus hoping to get
some more information about what has
happened he instead finds a massacre the
only living eternal he finds is icarus
and even then the prime eternal doesn't
survive for long icarus stays alive just
long enough to reveal that his people
erupted into madness when they learn
their true purpose essentially the dark
celestials meant for humanity to act as
a virus against an army of insects like
monsters called the horde and the
eternals were meant to cultivate that
virus and get humanity ready for the
harvesting before he succumbs his wounds
icarus gives iron man access to the uni
mind which the avengers are later able
to use to defeat the dark celestials in
2021 the eternals returned for the fifth
volume of their eponymous series this
story finds icarus and is a mortal
compatriot brought back from the dead
they are eternal after all set loose in
a battle against thanos icarus is killed
and rebirthed again and only then
discovers the horrible truth of the
eternal's immortality that they're
resurrected at the cost of human lives
unable to end this process without
endangering the earth the eternal set
out to solve their problem leading them
into a fragile alliance with their old
enemies the deviants
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
marvel comics are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]